let's also before we leave let's comment
on this
um tony hinchcliffe our friend
uh and i've been on kill tony many times
got himself into a little bit of a
pickle
he made a statement he's as a joke
he was saying something about the host
of a show and he called him a filthy
[ __ ]
something uh he's an asian gentleman
he's only really two or three but you're
gonna it was the
it was was not good it's the one that
lands not good
tony i do not believe is a hateful
person i don't believe he hates people i
don't believe he's racist
i believe he made and i said this on
twitter the worst decision a comic or
human anybody in that
particular moment can make in that time
that was not a good choice and people
got enraged about it angry about a
tony's a rose comic
what tony does uh is roast people now
outside of the show kill tony
that uh can be harrowing i guess that's
you know if you don't know tony as a
roast comic and you're not
in his element watching what he does and
how he does it
uh it can be uh disturbing and people
were obviously uh
unhappy with it that being said i will
say personally about tony
a lot of people have launched their
careers on kill tony black people
uh gay people he's helped me
dramatically he's helped other people
trans comics
there's a lot of people that have
traveled for hours and they've flown
states to go to kill tony for the chance
to do their set
and to get roasted by tony and to rose
tony um
you know he has guys with als michael
lehrer who's a brilliant comic with als
he has him on the show every week tony
does have a heart he's a human being
um and i think that reducing him to just
this collection of words
is unfortunate and they were the wrong
collection of words it was the wrong
thing to do it wasn't funny
it didn't work that being said to
diminish him as a human being because of
this
is a little ridiculous and of course we
all know what happens the agencies drop
them and this happens and that happens
and this is what
uh happens you know and to me knowing
him and knowing that
he has provided a platform he built
something and it's still a show and i'm
you know on twitter i said it meant
something to people and i talked to him
he's like you're staying at the past and
i'm like i know but right now it's
you know but it'll be back but i'm
saying that like the show meant
something to people
of all races genders sexual orientations
you can't just diminish that and i know
that
you know there's a lot and i didn't you
know the full sets i think provide a
little bit more context still it was
probably
not the best uh choice to make
in that moment but that's what being a
comedian is
you do make choices some of them are
good some of them are bad
um and it's hard you know seeing that
it's hard to see
where the funny would have been right
but a lot of people
will say things and then look back at it
and go ugh not
great you know me being one of them i
mean i've i've said all kinds of things
now usually everything i say is correct
and that's another burden
that i have the burden of being right
all the time about everything
which people don't think that's a burden
it's a terrible burden
where's my netflix special i'm right all
the time
and they don't like that okay
also stop talking about john mulaney and
his olivia munn leave him alone who
gives a [ __ ]
he stopped doing blow and he needs some
strange let him be
let him be the bad people in this
business are the ones who use words
people don't like
not the people who destroy their
families
[Music]
anyway those are the bad people don't
you get it
see you can do anything to anyone in
your personal life
as long as you say the right things do
you see what i mean
you never try and i'm not a moralist i'm
not saying to judge anyone morally for
their personal life
but what happens is in your personal
life you can do whatever you want
kids on the island in the cage [ __ ] it
who cares
come here honey doesn't matter as long
as you get out and you
say what is needed at the moment it's
needed it doesn't
matter what you behave like in fact
it almost feels like i don't know
it almost feels like saying
this [ __ ] that they want you to say
can inoculate you to a certain degree
from being judged in any other way
i'm sure that's not the case i'm sure
i'm wrong
but making life about words and phrases
and opinions
and not making it about character and
what people do and
if you're an entertainment i think it
should be about nothing i don't care if
you're funny or funny
melanie's a genius whatever you think
about whatever he's he's a comedic
like you know he's not my favorite
comedian but when i watch john mullaney
i go that guy is [ __ ] amazing
at this that's a fact and if you don't
think so
and and when i watch nick crowe i say
similar things like
it so yeah i mean the family's involved
in some
but who cares you know at the end of the
day it's to me
it truly is what you're doing on the
stage but what's interesting to me
is when everything becomes about words
and just
i have the right opinion in the right
package and that's good and
that's odd it's very interesting to me
that that's really what people care
about
hollywood is riddled with divorce with
abuse
uh with all kinds of problems as is
america
and uh but there's a real obsession with
having the right
posture on the right issues
and that's what it seems to be so
talking about this you have to realize
that i've seen
tony personally help people
of every race by giving them a platform
on the show by encouraging them after
the show
by having them open for them by doing
certain things by putting them
so the idea that you can reduce this guy
to just a sentence that he said which
was again
not wise but you you could reduce him to
that
after he's had a career of doing this
whether you like his comedy or not
the show that he built means something
to people and it has elevated people
uh and it has elevated them in cases
where the industry has not elevated them
and he's given a pathway for people to
earn money
uh blah blah blah so that's what it is
and that's that's what i have to say
about i did want to address it i know
other people will not be addressing it
of course
because they don't have platforms as
large as mine so
we will just say that um
you know and and that's what i'm saying
people need to be
able to be taken uh
the whole of what they've done has to be
judged not a few things here and a few
things there
who people are uh if you're going to
judge them you should judge them
on uh everything not so much just one
thing
so it is unfortunate